hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for this video
we're going to be talking about resting
liquidity okay and if you don't know
what resting liquidity it is basically
it's the orders that are already sitting
in the order book or orders as they are
coming into the order book and before we
jump in um if you've been enjoying my
videos be sure to subscribe to the
channel and click that notification Bell
so you don't miss any new uploads all
right
so you know there's sort of this
argument that goes back and forth
sometimes uh among Traders what is
orderflow right I believe order flow is
the footprint chart right you can see
the ORD is actually being traded in the
market and there's a school of thought
that says no orderflow is the market
depth right uh you know the Dome so to
speak you know where orders are coming
into the Dome or sorry the depth of the
market right people are placing orders
uh into the market that that's the order
flow well it's really a matter of
semantics okay and you know if you've
been around the markets long enough you
understand that orders coming can be
amended right they could be um pulled as
the market gets close but what's more
important do you think Traders
intentions like where they're placing
orders in the market so you know say for
example right here right the market was
trading uh 5011 and there's big order up
here at 5015 is that important well
we're four four points away from the
market okay what do you think is going
to be more important what the market is
actually trading right now at this
moment how it's trading on the bid and
how it's trading on the offer or
people's intentions
because when a person actually trades
when a trade goes through the market
generally that Trader is committed to
the market right that they have a
position on that they're going to want
to get out of at some point Point as
opposed to yeah I would love to sell at
5015 when the Market's trading 5011 but
that's not going to happen it's too far
off the market I mean sure the market
could Spike up but most likely it's not
going to happen however that's not to
say that resting liquidity is not
without value to a Trader it is okay
because there are times there are
instances where an order will come in
and it will have an effect on the market
okay but I know I see it all too often
where Traders think that looking at the
depth of the market is sort of like the
um missing piece if you will well okay
let's take a look at some of this
liquidity in the market okay so this was
today um what's today's date the 7th of
of
Feb and around 1056 a big order came in
at 5015 okay we had traded 5015 earlier
in the day okay um we got up there just
uh the high for the day on this day was
uh 15 and a quar that was made at 931
okay then we came off and you can see at
15 you know there's not big size in
there there's
192 um for the next hour or so okay and
then it sort of builds up a little bit
243 and
then later here right around 1056
1057 uh a big size order comes in now
there's all of a sudden 700 58
contracts in the order book at
5015 and people will say well yeah
that's why the market sold off here okay
you can see it's one of those uh
shooting star type candles where it's
trading up but then someone plops in a
big order here it gets as high as what
is that 13 and a quarter so you know
almost two points away it's
17 seven ticks away so 1.75 points is
that enough to cause this Market to drop
well maybe in the short term okay what
happens in the market does it sell off
well over the next 5 minutes it it
basically it drops from you know 11 down
to what 9 and A4 now bear in mind right
if you're a dome Trader right a lot of
guys that trade off the Dome they're
just looking to you know get a few ticks
here and there right two ticks three
ticks four ticks you know back and forth
so yeah maybe they could have profited
from this trade in the sense that the
big liquidity came in here the big order
to offer resistance in the
market and it dropped you know two
points okay I could see that
argument then later it's just going
sideways it dropped a little bit further
got down here to 07 the market started
rallying back up but there's no big bid
down here I mean at at ' 05 there's 202
contracts that's not a big bid it's not
782 and again you know one thing that I
learned early on in the markets is the
the market is attracted to size size
acts actually as a magnet because if
you're a big Trader you want to trade
against size you want to be trading
against a market that's IL liquid and
bear in mind right the
market today was going up and if you're
a big Trader if you're an Institutional
Trader and you got a lot to sell where's
the easiest place to sell it's easiest
to sell in a rising market not in a
falling market right if you got a lot of
Supply that you need to sell a lot of
S&S you need to sell you want to sell it
into a rising market so am I shocked to
see 782 coming up here at 15 no right
just as I'm not shocked to see at 17
there's
325 okay so then the market dips down
and finally we Spike up and we trade
through it right we we get up through 15
and we actually get all the way up to 16
and a
half and then you can start seeing what
the depth is at 18 is 300 at 18 so at 15
177 18 decent
size and remember if you're a big Trader
it's easiest to sell into a rising
market because that's just going to get
bought up by um Traders are coming into
the market because the Market's going up
but let's take a look at when it shot up
through here because this isn't acting
as resistance as everyone thought it
would and remember if you're a dome
Trader if you're trading off of a dome
generally you know you're looking for to
scalp a few ticks and it blew right
through it got one from 15 all the way
up to 16 and and a half maybe you have a
two-point stop okay that's eight ticks
but if you're just trying to scalp three
or four ticks you would have been
stopped out now let's go take a look
here at what happened when it got up
through uh 15 here where is that here so
you see the 890 traded there and then it
trades 15 and a quarter 15 and a half 16
16 16 and a quarter 16 and a half is the
high right then it then it sold off okay
yeah I mean had you had a limit order in
there either you know right ahead you
know Everyone likes to jump in front of
size for some reason to me that's like
jumping in front of a freight train um
you know you're getting short at 15 as
the Market's coming up to 15 and this
Market just sort of jumped up there you
can see the aggressive trading and
you're you're short at 15 gets all the
way up to 16 maybe you're stopped out
depending on where your stop is that's
two
points if you had a wide stop yeah maybe
you could have taken advantage of
shorting at 15 for a move all the way
down to you know down in here where
spent some time at 07 for the next 5
minutes okay that's a great trade if
that's the way you're trading off of a
dome or trading off of a market depth
map
now going back here to the market depth
map right then you see there's still
more size coming in here at 16 17 as you
got closer it started getting pulled
remember there was how much was there
here here at one point I think at 17
there's 334 contracts
okay 334 at
17 and you can see when it trades up to
17 trades 209 comes off trades another
526 on the offer okay so obviously that
order was Iceberg and every time you
have that resting liquidity here in the
market it trades through it trades
through it trades through
okay so if if you're thinking that oh my
gosh you know like here right now okay
this is what time is it it's about uh 1
15 117 in the morning or in the
afternoon um you know you can see the
liquidity up here at 19 and a quarter up
here at 20 you know there's probably
more these probably these volumes there
probably Iceberg orders in here honestly
um but don't think for a second
that this is going to offer resistance
that the Market's got a reverse off of
this it didn't reverse here it didn't
reverse here didn't reverse
here okay cuz remember the key to
trading
size is size attracts size it attracts
big Traders okay and sort of again there
is a use
for a market depth map now I'm not
comparing or ninja Traders Market depth
map to book map book map is very loaded
with featur
um but if if you're not using bookmap if
you're just looking at the raw data here
of the the market depth map from you
know ninja Trader which basically just
is just taking the data off of the
footprint chart or sorry off the um the
Dome you know people get mesmerized by
size and they think the Market's got to
react to it no a lot of times the market
will trade through
it and then what if you're if you're
jumping in front of the eyes right you
jump in front
here I'm assuming you got to stop in
right and people say oh yeah you could
have sold it up here at 15 and covered
it down here at 08 or 09 well what kind
of stop do you have I mean if if you're
jumping in front of size looking for a
big
reaction you're probably going to have a
tight
stop so just bear that in mind I guess
you know the whole point is you know
there's nothing wrong with looking at a
market depth
map but just bear mind that you
know size attracts size and sometimes
trying to jump in front of size resting
liquidity that's been there in the
market isn't always the most prudent
thing to do okay and again you know when
I first started trading electronically
it was back in the 90s when it was on
the old Globex system and I I would just
sit there all night because I work the
night shift and we just watch the Dome
what's trading you know what the
liquidity is in the market nowadays you
you got very good size this is bonds but
if I were to put put it on uh e
minis you know back in those days S&P
were training in the 400s
500s and you know big size then was 30
contracts but uh you know times have
changed so I guess the point is if there
is a point people say what's your point
but um don't get mesmerized so much by
size
because the market is attracted to size
sometimes it acts as a magnet okay don't
think that you got to jump in in front
of it and try to short it okay so if if
this helps a few Traders save you know
themselves from a couple bad trades
great I'm glad you found it helpful be
sure to hit that uh like button and I'll
catch you guys on the next video
bye-bye